Sometimes DNA test results can be confusing.
For example, you might find that you and one
of your relatives don’t share any DNA.
There are a couple of reasons for that.
Maybe your family tree is actually
a little different from what you’ve been told.
But sometimes it’s just biology —
specifically a process called recombination.
That’s when chromosomes swap DNA.
DNA contains the instructions for building your body.
At the molecular level,
it’s shaped like a twisted ladder.
Inside your cells,
these DNA ladders are arranged
in long strands called chromosomes.
People usually have 23 pairs of chromosomes.
Half of each pair comes from your mother
and the other half from your father.
But long before egg meets sperm,
something interesting happens to your parents’ DNA
Inside the cells that become eggs or sperm,
chromosomes pair up.
Pieces of DNA from one chromosome switch places
with pieces of DNA from the other chromosome.
This swapping, or recombination, of DNA is important.
It injects diversity into the mix and
ensures that you get just one copy
of each chromosome from each parent.
Each generation does its own genetic shuffle.
So grandma and grandpa each mix up the DNA
they inherited from your great-grandparents.
Half of that recombined DNA
goes to your mom or dad.
Then your parent’s DNA undergoes similar shuffling
before it’s passed on to you.
To recap,
you inherit about 50 percent of each parent’s DNA
and about 25 percent of each grandparent’s DNA.
But because you don’t get a carbon copy
of the DNA your parents inherited from their parents,
there’s some wiggle room in these numbers.
Depending on where the recombination happens
on the chromosomes,
you could inherit a lot of DNA from your grandfather
and very little from your grandmother.
So, you and your siblings end up with
different DNA mixes from your parents
(unless you’re identical twins).
And you and your cousins get different
genetic heirlooms from your grandparents.
First and second cousins usually share DNA,
but because of recombination,
about 10 percent of third cousins won’t share any DNA.
The same goes for about half of fourth cousins.
That doesn’t mean you’re not related.
You still have common family members,
and that counts as much or more
than having DNA in common.
[music]